welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for today's webinar tissue
Tripps building confidence through
independent experimental testing
presented by dr. Yvonne rusyn professor
college of veterinary medicine and
biomedical sciences Texas A&M University
my name is Xavier Q tears and I will be
your moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots lab
roots is the leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
now before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. rusyn I will
now turn the presentation over to him
well hello to you all and thank you for
your interest in lab roots and in this
particular conference it was a privilege
for me to participate and I also wanted
to thank lab roots for organizing these
events and for scheduling these
educational webinars so as I said my job
today is to tell you about our
experiences with testing tissue chips as
you can see on the screen toxicologist
by training and I also have an MD and I
came to interacting with tissue chips as
a biomedical researcher and a
mechanistic toxicologist and before I
begin I wanted to have a disclaimer a
couple of years ago I was interviewed by
natural medicine for a future article
that they were putting
together on chip power and a couple of
quotes that they used in that particular
article reflected how I felt about
tissue chips and micro physiological
systems two years ago and in part my
presentation today will be a transition
of me personally as a scientist and as a
toxicologist and what type of confidence
I was able to build into myself and into
the stakeholders that we collaborate
with so I said that I don't want to
assume that more complicated system is
better and as you can imagine tissue
chips are much more complicated than
traditional in vitro systems and I also
said that I was at that time healthy
skeptic about tissue chips and how much
promise they can actually hold and I did
feel that a number of developers have
over-promised with respect to what they
can deliver and this was something that
we probably all seen before with
promising technology not living up to
its expectations and perhaps fading much
sooner than it can really deliver
because the expectations were much
greater so what we have tried to do in
the last couple of years is to help both
the by engineers and the end users to
have greater confidence in tissue chips
as a technology that can be used for
safety and toxicity testing and also in
other parts of drug development so
before I begin giving you the data I
wanted to thank National Center for
advancing translational Sciences for
funding us with a two-year grant in 2016
and this year or late last year they
actually funded us again for two more
years but all of the data that we have
been able to collect as a tissue chip
testing Center Texas A&M University was
really a product of four very able
postdocs and technicians and then we
have a couple of people that are helping
out analytical chemistry and I'll share
some of that data with you as well
and most importantly we have a number of
faculty who we are able to reach out for
consultation
there's really myself and dr. prefer
Stefan at one of our partner
organizations
Asians that have overseen the laboratory
experiments but most important are very
grateful to our collaborators from nine
universities that have shared their
devices with us that have posted our
staff in their laboratories to learn how
to use their technology and who have
stayed interacting with us with respect
to protocols and data analysis and
interpretation of their results so I'm
really grateful not only to principal
investigators but also to their students
technicians and postdocs who have really
gone out of their way working with us so
I wanted to start at the very beginning
and this slide as the court is the
courtesy of dr. Danilo Tagle from MCATs
and MCATs is one of the funding agencies
that is part of National Institutes of
Health in the United States that has
been funding a lot of biomedical
engineering research into developing
initiatives so as you can see at the
bottom of your screen and Katz has
provided a number of grants and I will
tell you more about them on the next
couple of slides that our aim to develop
micro physiological systems that
replicate organ function and structure
that can be used to test compounds that
can be actually taken outside of the
laboratory and these particular devices
are meant to be beyond just the
publication and something of an academic
interest they're really meant to be used
by the stakeholders and that's what you
see on the very top the industry and
regulatory agencies really are the ones
that are prospective users of this
technology and most importantly this
particular technology if people have
confidence in it and if it really works
can be something that contract research
organizations can provide as a service
to multiple clients to build up the data
and to increase further confidence in
using these types of data for decision
making in regulatory environments
however as frequently happens there is a
large gap between the people who develop
technology and people who can be
potential users of this particular
technology and that gap in biomedical
sciences is very challenging to bridge
and MCATs designed the Chrome
- brain tissue chip testing centers who
would be trying to be the bridge between
the technology developers and the
technology users because there's a lot
of writing not only in terms of finances
but also the advances of drug
development and chemical safety
evaluation on this so n caz issue the
program announcement in 2016 and the
call for proposals that would last for
about two years that would test two to
three new devices about every six months
and would have a throughput of a couple
of compounds and tested for a couple of
different phenotypes and replicate a
couple of times so really two and a half
years they don't know what to do what is
the opportunity and whether this to show
chip testing is impossible so n Katz has
called this program announcement
next-gen tissue chip testing centers
validating micro physiological system
and validation means different thing in
different contexts or what you can see
on the left at FDA analytical and
clinical validation is really something
that is quite established I'm using
excuse me an example of US Food and Drug
Administration but you know they're very
similar principles in Europe and in
other countries and validation really is
broken into both analytical and clinical
validation and in both of these contexts
one women needs to understand how the
device or how the test will be used and
once you understand the context of use
for that particular device you can
understand where the bar is for how good
that technology should be and once you
understand the use and what the level of
evidence one needs you can actually
embark on the process of qualification
the qualification of biomarkers
qualification of server instruments and
other things in you know in drug world
it's not an easy process that takes
years and it takes many stakeholders now
on the chemical side there's you know
validation of alternative methods that
many of you may be familiar with and
that's a process that is very rigorously
regulated and specified by a number of
legal documents and frameworks
in Europe for example the cosmetics
directive and the reach regulation
describe what validation alternative
methods really is the United States
Japan Korea Brazil and other countries
there are very parallel efforts and
internationally an organization of
Economic Cooperation and Development
OECD is actually a guideline that is a
guidance document of validation and the
traditional acceptance of new or updated
test methods for hazard assessment and
the guidelines states that there are
three components of three major elements
and validation there is a testing of
reliability there's a testing of
relevance and then there has to be a
purpose in which this particular test
will be used and so when this comes to
tissue chips and the vision that MCATs
had two and a half years ago for what
tissue chip testing centers should do it
was so not entirely clear which ones of
these qualifications or validations
there is its reliability or is it
relevance and it was left to the
grantees of people who wanted to solicit
for these particular grants to define
what that meant so first thing that we
had to start with was to define what
tissue chips are out there and MCAD
specified that the tissue chip testing
centers were only to work with
developers who have been funded by MCATs
and in 2012 there was a first round of
grants awarded and all of this
information is available on MCATs
website a futures google and cats and
tissue chip you'll be led to a website
that has plenty of information on the
developers on what they've done what
they've published and a lot of
information is provided for you but as
you can see there is a diversity of
institutions there's a diversity of the
projects of tissues or models that have
been proposed and we reached out to all
of these and then we ended up with about
2/3 of the developers who were
interested in working with us and as I
will say at the end of this presentation
you know one of the challenges is to
actually convinced people who develop
technology to let third party test the
technology before it actually hits real
world and that's just the reality and
I'm not really taking sighs invest
myself now when we proposed to
due to suit your testing center as you
can see we have attacks now as our title
and we're at the Texas A&M University in
College Station Texas we really reason
that this is it takes a village to do
this type of work you need to have
experts from different disciplines as
you can see this puzzle board at the
bottom left
you need to have expertise in toxicology
analytical chemistry and by engineering
and micro fluidics you to have folks who
understand how to use these data kinetic
modeling there are a lot of measurements
that are being taken that are very
diverse from protein measurements to
gene expression to images and then you
have to do this at GOP like environment
so you have to make sure that your work
is actually quality control as well but
there are other parameters and core
principles that were important to us
first we really wanted to make sure that
our team of scientists is independent of
the MCATs fund initiative developers so
as you can see on the next click we have
a diversity of faculty and even though
some of them are by engineers they're
not funded currently by MCAT so we
really had no conflict of interest as
far as we are concerned it's like an
important thing that I wanted to
highlight is that you really need to
compare the data from the 3d micro
physiological system to the standard in
vitro culture model it is also important
to compare to the ánewá situation
whenever possible but because in
principle these micro physiological
systems are using cells then recreating
some form of a much simpler system that
probably has a higher throughput and can
be attainable by more laboratories was
something that was very important to us
and unfortunately and the bio
engineering world that issue should
develop the world very few labs actually
provide comparison to the 2d systems so
we had a complicated or two chart and
I'm not going to take you through it for
there a long time just to point out that
not only it takes a village of a lot of
different people with a lot of different
expertise for to have this type of a
throughput to test 8 to 12 platforms in
years you willing to have capacity to do
this and so we were fortunate to have
two different sites at Texas A&M
University one in Houston one in College
Station was about an hour-and-a-half
drive between these two facilities we
had two labs in Houston and four labs in
College Station that kind of came
together and interacted on a weekly
basis and changed exchanged compounds
that change data change protocol and
information but we also were interacting
very closely with our tissue chip
developers is I already mentioned but
also that's not the end of it we had
monthly teleconferences with our funder
and cats but also with representatives
of various pharmaceutical companies that
have since organized into the IQ
consortium affiliate or micro
physiological systems and last but not
least all of the data that we're
generating we're depositing into the
University of Pittsburgh micro
physiological systems database this was
one of the grants awarded under this
mechanism and I again welcome you to go
and explore micro physiological systems
database again huge interest Google for
that and you can easily find it now the
as I already mentioned this type of an
effort that I will describe to you in
some detail took only about two years
and for those of you in academia you
certainly would appreciate that two
years is a very short period of time
because by the time you actually get
funding in and actually start projects
hire staff and actually you know begin
doing things you already lost valuable
time so we had to devise a standardized
workflow that we can follow
not only for every chip but also to
organize our work now Rene mentioned
that we try to test devices in about a
six months period because we reasoned
that in the real world and whether it's
a pharmaceutical or a chemical company
or contract research organization there
are people who are not developing the
particular model will not have long
enough staying power if it really
doesn't work in couple of months then
it's not worth investing more time and
you need to move on to something so we
try to use very similar thinking process
you also see that there are different
tiers there are different steps the
first step is really to establish a
collaboration and there is a tremendous
amount of legal agreements that have to
be negotiated between the universities
to change this change the technology and
they do other things that the share
protocols you have to actually go in and
send staff to train in the developer
labs once you through that then you
actually get the devices and you try to
put it all together in your lab and then
without sales try to see if you can
establish flow or if you can do other
things and at that step we usually
started putting chemicals on these
devices and examining whether or not we
have a lot of binding of chemicals to
these devices because they're made of
various types of materials and many of
these materials combined you know
compounds especially based on their
physical chemical properties then once
we are through with that we can actually
try to replicate what the developers
have published or were just about to
publish and we would develop in that
process very detailed protocols and
standard operating procedures and if
we're through with that through our
conversations with our colleagues in
pharmaceutical companies and other
toxicologists who try to define some
form of the context of use for each of
these models and we'll try to conduct
additional studies that can gain
additional attention from the potential
end users that can actually answer some
of the questions very practical
questions that they have that may or may
not have been addressed in the original
publication that just described the
technology itself so I was very pleased
that over these two years we were able
to complete 11 different tissue chip
platforms you can see on the left or the
diversity of tissues and models there's
only one that was you know similar and I
will tell you more about this we had two
models of deliver all of these is
already mentioned were funded by MCATs
there are a lot of other technology
platforms out there there are other
universities there are other companies
that develop that we had to focus on
what was funded by MCATs
we had collaborated with nine different
universities and we have got to complete
a variety of legal agreements with them
and we've tested seven of these in
college station or four of these in
Houston and as you can see by the Ambo
2018 we've been able to take 10 of the
11 all the way through tier two and then
one of the platforms was thought that
tier 1 because of the throughput and
other challenges that we had if you look
at the timeline more of a Gantt chart
like new you see that we started in two
sides the maroon is College Station the
blue is our site in Houston and we got
confidence and working with the
developers getting into this workflow
and then our next period was more
confidence with a couple of platforms in
each site and then towards the end we
really kind of were confident in our
ability to run multiple platforms in
parallel so we were able to work with
three to five different platforms at the
same time so let me give you a couple of
examples of what the data looks like and
I broken these slides in two types of
profusion or black they're all from
these particular models because for me
as a toxicologist that was very
interesting to learn that in the field
of biomedical engineering tissue chip or
micro physiological is not really you
know very well defined terms and really
each laboratory defines what is micro
physiological what is or is not a tissue
chip themselves and as long as they can
convince peer reviewers to publish
papers and if they can convince funders
to get more grants that's how they
proceed what this micro physiological
but obviously each platform is trying to
replicate either a tissue either organ
or some part there off and then it
actually is trying to replicate some
sort of physiology or or anatomy on the
micro scale so a good couple of examples
were platforms that actually have no
flow there static cultures but they are
very complicated cultures one is bone
with and without tumor model from
Columbia University and what this is is
essentially a plate which has chambers
and these chambers containing them
pieces of this authorized bovine
trabecular bone that have been seen it
with human osteoblasts than you in
sarcoma cells since it
human tissue but there is no flow and
our tissue and what we have done after
repeating the experiments that the
colleagues at Columbia University did
actually try to do or simulate treatment
of metastases into the bone and we try
to look at which drugs are used in the
clinic and which regiments are being
used so we would first culture these
platforms after receiving them from
Columbia for seven days and then
depending on the particular treatment
whether cisplatin methotrexate and
Christine dexamethasone or a combination
of drugs we try to treat for several
consecutive days and then have an off
period and then treat again and then
evaluate growth of youin sarcoma cells
two weeks after the termination of
treatment and so we've done all of this
in comparison as I mentioned with
two-dimensional culture were just
culture doing sarcoma cells and what you
see here is viability two weeks after
termination of treatment and we
normalize everything to the growth rate
of the Ewing sarcoma cells without any
treatment that's the controls across the
top of this bar graph and then you can
see there is a concentration response
we've tested human c-max and then kind
of you know half an order of magnitude
or an order of magnitude above or below
and you can see you can kill Ewing
sarcoma cells with cisplatin you could
there's a clear concentration response
with methotrexate in both models when
christine is very effective now the
interesting difference was with text
amethyst own dexamethasone rule is not
supposed to have any effect on Ewing
sarcoma cells but it was toxic to the
osteoblasts and so Ewing sarcoma cells
were dying as they were losing the
support of the osteoblasts and then the
combination treatment was more effective
at 3d so there are important differences
between 2d and 3d but there's a you know
the biggest difference to me is how much
variability is there in the 3d platform
because it's very difficult to control
the number of Ewing's sarcoma cells that
are being seeded into this model so you
have to have an effect that is really
pronounced the fact that it's very
difficult to achieve statistical
significance and have a very good
titration of concentration responses
compared to the 2g system and y'all
so may have some of these unexpected
effects like the we seen with the
dexamethasone another platform that's
really a static culture but still has a
microphone a logical nature - it was a
intestinal and turmeric model that was
developed jointly by scientists at Johns
Hopkins University and Baylor College of
Medicine and this is a co culture of
different cells from the gut and some of
them are IPS derived and some of them
are primary cells or self cell lines and
these are propagated as intra voids for
them once you start testing them this is
really the Transvaal system where you
have a monolayer of this called culture
and then you can add drugs you know into
the trans well and then measure
permeability or you can measure
permeability in the reverse order as
well and you know I'm not going to show
you a lot of data but just as an example
the published data is on the left from
Johns Hopkins and Baylor College of
Medicine
they were looking at transit Bethulia
electrical resistance the measure of the
barrier function of this particular
model and as you can see the tear is
going up with days of differentiation
that's what you need to see and on the
right is very similar data obtained by
our colleagues in Houston the Transit
Authority or electrical resistance goes
up as it should be going and then the
permeability to fit see label dextran is
is actually decreasing so again the
barrier does take a couple of data or
days to establish but there's a pretty
nice barrier that he could test and
again I will not you know belabor the
point of the amount of the data that
we've collected with this model system
were tested two dozen different drugs
and this is the graph of how we selected
these drugs there was actually a lot of
data on Keiko to model versus human
absorption in the gut and we tried to
test compounds that actually have you
know very good concordance with the
compounds that actually don't have a
very good concordance between K co2 and
human absorption and all of this data
will be submitted for publication and
that's couple of months as we're still
working through analytical chemistry on
these data now the other types of
platforms that we've seen
were based on perfusion but it's a
profusion that is driven by gravity so
there are no pumps that are involved in
this particular experiment and all you
have is as the example on the left of
the hard limit chip or cardiac model
from years to california-berkeley you
can see the model is pretty small two of
these chips can fit on one histological
slide in the middle on the top you see
the there's about 50,000 cardiomyocytes
that are tightly packed into a chamber
and then the perfusion is actually
happening along the side so there's a
passive diffusion of media and drug into
the system and then you can see on the
top right that there by the tips that
are filled with media and then the media
just flows from one side to the next and
then at equilibrate and then you can
replace the media next day or in a
couple of days and we unfortunately
cannot show you the movies these are the
two slides on me on the bottom in this
box but you can see that you know these
are different experiments and the rep
reduced ability of how many cells we can
actually get into this chamber is
actually pretty good and the types of
data that we're collecting is actually
beating so there's a video microscopy of
these cells beating after a couple of
days of culture in this chamber and it's
very well known that you can get
cardiomyocytes to beat in culture in the
traditional 2g system and what you see
in blue on the middle left is these
cardiomyocytes beat in both directions
kind of there's a mounted directionality
of beating but our colleagues from
Berkeley have published on this model
they've shown that if you pack them into
this particular chamber you force them
to beat only in one direction so there
you can actually measure contractility
lb if we did do this in our experiments
and at the bottom you can see that we
can establish the same directionality of
beating if you see collar that means
that the cells are pooling in one
direction and they're not pulling in the
orthogonal direction and then you can
test different drugs and concentration
response you can do
an escalation of the dose in the same
device or you can you know do other time
series or other types of experiments and
you can derive effective concentrations
and you can prepare those to these Tmax
or or other types of experiments and
again you can see that both us and the
developers have published the developers
have published couple of papers where
they've compared their results to those
of humans he max a couple of known drugs
and these work very similar which gives
confidence in this technology that we
have not published our data yet but we
get very similar data which again you
know it is a good result and something
that we're very glad to see another
model that is based on gravity driven
profusion I'll be it not with the piped
tips but more of the reservoirs and that
particular platform is the best he'll
rise to her model from years to
california-irvine labs and this
particular model if you see on the right
there first generation was you know a
glass slide with actual chambers that
were filled with media they have since
miniaturized this into more of a 96-well
plate like organization they're actually
twelve devices because each has a number
of chambers that are actually
constituting one device but you know
this is higher throughput because you
can actually work with twelve devices at
the same time so this is data from a
publication from the developers you can
see that endothelial cells are better
seen in two together with cancer cells
form networks and in red are endothelial
cells and they're very nice networks and
then in green or fluorescent cancer
cells and in this particular experiment
they had four different cancer cell
lines that were seeded into their
devices and then you can add different
drugs to this you know passive perfusion
system and you can compare cytotoxicity
of those anti-cancer drugs both in a 2g
system and in a 3d system so it's you
know not a technology that's you know
very easy to establish however in our
lab we were able to successfully
we establish these endothelial cell
networks we can see on top is the phase
contrast image and then on the middle
and bred is a material cell network and
then at the bottom in green is the same
device that has been perfused from one
side with fitzy dextran so not only
these are cords of endothelial cells
these are actually perfusing both
channels and as you can see if it's the
next trend entered on one side actually
fills in the network of the vessels in
this particular device and again there's
a lot of data that we have generated
that I don't have time to know what into
right now now the last couple of devices
that I wanted to show you are actually
active perfusion or pump driven systems
and again there are you know additional
complications for this so the first
example I wanted to give you is the
proximal tubule device that was
developed at the University of
Washington and this device is based on a
commercial chip from company called
mortis that can be used a couple of
different ways and I'll show you on the
next couple slides an alternative way
this chip was used but in essence this
is a part of a nephron this is not
kidney on the chip this is you know
doesn't have a glomerulus but you there
are a lot of questions about drugs and
chemicals and there are effects in the
proximal tubules so it just you know
represented really useful micro
physiological model and then once you
actually you know put this all together
it's a channel that is lined up with
renal proximal tubule epithelial cells
and this is the channel that is perfused
with media this is the system that can
be either closed in these particular
enclosures that you can acquire from
laura's and in the middle here you can
see how this is all looking in the
standard tissue culture incubator you
can fit about 24 of these chips and you
know one challenge with these models is
they are not you know 24-hour or
one-week experiments it takes about a
week to actually get the channel
established and fusible and then after
that you can do this experiment for a
couple of weeks and
survive quite nicely and so we both use
the devices from Lourdes and just the
regular syringe pumps that are much more
economical way of doing these
experiments and the results are
essentially the same so it's not how
fancy your devices or your setup is its
how technically skilled you are and also
how well you can differentiate between
different cell sources so the results of
this particular technologies have been
technology have been published couple
months ago and this is an open access
publication I invite you to go and find
this and read it in greater detail but
one of the things that we were really
interested in is whether there is a
difference and where you get the
architects so our collaborators from
University of Washington have shared
with us a couple of vials of more or
less primary architects that they have
isolated from donor tissue in the
University of Washington and then we
procure itself from lanza which is a
commercial supplier there are other
companies as well and there was no
particular reason we have used cells
from lawns or some not a chain for that
particular source in any way and here
this is the data on gene expression as
you can see these particular cells from
both sources express kidney specific
biomarkers both injury biomarkers and
kidney metabolism and transform
biomarkers one important thing I wanted
to point out is that the basal
expression are dramatic for important
things like Kim Won you can see an HIV
cr1 which is the Kim one is expressed at
a much higher level in ones of cells and
but then liquid calcium 2 is actually
expressed at low levels but still you
can see that in more primary architects
versus ones that you can get from loans
up but then what we did with these data
actually compare gene expression
profiles to human kidney cortex data
from another NIH project called tissue
gene expression consortium gtex and as
you can see can make cortex is on the
top and red and our two different
architects in culture either 2d or 3d
are towards the bottom so they're not
with
identical and their gene expression
profile - kidney cortex but what you can
see is it's really doesn't matter how
you culture these cells it's the cell
source that is actually driving the
differences in gene expression and then
the figure on the bottom right shows
that with different treatments that we
have subjected these cells to women the
gene expression profiling again you have
grouping or clustering of far cells or
data by their source rather than by the
actual treatment and that's a very
important point to recognize now the
actual experiment that we described in
this study were again comparing and
contrasting m31 and ones of cells and
you can culture these cells for up to 28
days both in 2d and in 3d you can see
the channel 3d in fluidic you see the
cells are elongated with the flow and
they're more haphazard and just entered
in the 2d culture and then you know kim
won levels again a much much higher and
lots of cells then and they in 31
architects and again they kind of you
know steady up as you go on with culture
and this is you know very healthy
culture if you're not treating it with
anything and we really aim to replicate
what the developers have published so on
the right you can see key data from
webinar all 2016 publication and kidney
international and what our collaborators
did they not only describe the model
they also put this model to the test
with respect to its physiology so in the
middle on the right you see that they
have looked at switchin vitamin d
metabolism with you know an addition of
khalsa trial and then also induce
abilities other company for fifteen
twenty four eighty one when you actually
switch they buy the minty metabolism and
at the bottom they found that as they
lower ph of their profusion media they
actually see an increase in ammonia
generation so we tried to replicate
these key elements of their publication
plus we also tested poly mix and me
effects and that's those are panels
across the top in the middle ones and
you can see that polymyxin B was toxic
to our P text in 2d in both lungs on him
31 cells but him 31 cells were very
resilient Atul makes them be in 3d
system when lanza cells really died off
in the 3d chip and important point of
biomarkers of injuring Kim Won you can
see it go up very early if you can
collect enough profuse 8 in these models
but as you can see with logs of cells at
48 hours you see Kim bond is actually
going down and it's not because there is
less toxicity there's actually fewer to
know cells to generate Kim Won and to
shed that into the media but more
important or interesting findings were
with vitamin D metabolism we found that
both him 131 cells and lungs of cells
induced cytochrome p450 2041 in 3d
culture not in 2d culture when we added
calcitriol but we did not see the change
in metabolite information with lanza
cells when but with him so in one cells
we saw a very similar effect as in the
published publication but with ammonia
genesis we actually found an opposite
result so as we lower the pH of the
media we saw a decrease ammonia
generation so we overall concluded in
that paper that the key elements as far
as physiology vitamin D metabolism
induced ability of the metabolic enzymes
is reprimands probably do depend very
greatly on a particular donor of cells
or a particular source source of the
cells that you get but if you can in
room as you probably remember we also
had this you know last tier which is
trying to define the context of use and
trying to do more than the developers
have done themselves as they were
developing the technology and what we've
done we've tested a variety of
nephrotoxic drug cisplatin gentamicin
and cadmium and we have shown that there
was a time dependent and concentration
dependent oxy city that we can replicate
in this model and then more importantly
we have collected a number of data
points trying to understand whether this
particular model can be used in for
pharmacokinetic modeling and again that
particular data is still under review
being submitted but the complication of
the PvP came Auto
PK modeling
this particular chip and it's a single
compartment there is really not a blood
compartment there is not a filtration in
this particular system so we're only
measuring reabsorption of sorts kind of
deficit or disappearance of a chemical
from a profuse aid but we were able to
replicate with cisplatin gentamicin and
cadmium actually very closely the the
clearance and reabsorption when we
combine both the data that we collect
and a PV became model that was developed
for this particular instance as you can
see cisplatin clearance to filtration
rate is greater than 1 in vivo and we
have replicated that for gentamicin it's
about even clearance and glimmer or
filtration and then cadmium is being you
know clearance is much lower than
filtration so it's being actively
reabsorbed we can establish that and the
conclusions that we drew from that
particular study is that multiple
reabsorption can be estimated with this
particular model you really need a baby
became model to draw some conclusions
about the overall clearance but could
much greater confidence can be gained by
potential end users if you actually have
a tubular secretion component as well
and that's exactly the direction that
our collaborators diffusion reversed
your washington have taken they develop
the next generation of this model where
they're you know two parallel tubes and
this is the model that we'll be testing
actually and February March and April of
2019
now another example of a pro fusible
system is two models of deliver these
this one on the top was developed at
University of Pittsburgh by les Seiler
and Larimer Mattie and it's a nortis
chip that uses a different part of the
chip there was a chamber that is filled
with cells not only about a size but
also other non-breakable cells and you
can see an image of how this actually
looks in the incubator the pump is in
the incubator because the perfusion
distance is pretty short and we've
tested both primary human Matis eyes
from thermal and also IPS derived from
Fujifilm parasites and we've it takes
about two days to establish this
platform and then we tested it for up to
14 days you can sample media daily you
can also do imaging daily on this
platform the
second one was from University of
california-berkeley from Kevin Keeley
this is a device that is made in dr.
Haley's laboratory it's actually a true
team two channel system it's one channel
divided by a membrane so you seed cells
and in this particular case only besides
without lung parenchyma cells into one
chamber and then you profuse through
different chamber and again I said back
to the refuse system it takes about one
day to test and we again tested the
cells that developers tested from a
different supplier still primary data
size from lawns on then the same
supplier IPS dry for parasites and
imaging is a big challenge for this
particular model because the membrane is
on a fluorescent and that really gives
you a problem with seeing into the
device so just to show you a couple of
data points folks usually test the
functionality of parasites and culture
by measuring albumin and urea nitrogen
secretion we can see the dotted lines
with thermo primary parasites these
levels of low into D culture and then in
3d culture both ourselves and University
of Pittsburg collaborators who had the
same batch of cells we have very similar
results and albumin levels and urea
nitrogen levels are very high and
maintained over up to two weeks and then
with Berkeley device we had a different
source of manna sites and really had the
opposite result there was no albumin
secretion and blood urea nitrogen levels
really went away down so here one cannot
conclude whether it's a device or the
outer size from that particular donor
and that particular source that we're
the reason why this was not a very good
result but when you have the same type
of cells and in this particular case
Fujifilm
so dynamics international I can't write
parasites with the same NPC fraction we
actually have found that we have a very
similar result to the one we showed with
thermal parasites but in this case we
could compare it across two different
platforms
again the results are very very similar
so it's not the device it's actually the
source of cells that is very important
something that we have found with the
kidney device as well but the
functionality is not ending with just
human and urea
attrition so metabolism is very
important and we've done a lot of
experiments one example I'm going to
show you with adding to funding to the
perfusion media and then measuring both
affinity and information effects of
energy that requires metabolism by
cytochrome p450 3a4 and as you can see
in 2d on the left in the first day of
culture we do have fax defendant
information but that metabolism really
goes away as you keep culturing these
cells but in a 3d system fax defendant
information is consistent as we add as
we change media and add more turf energy
and we actually form fexofenadine very
consistently and then with ICL
hepatocytes very similar results in too
deep there's metabolism over first
couple of days but then there's a very
consistent metabolism over time in the
3d culture and then with Berkeley Lanza
hepatocytes not surprisingly or not
doing much and with respect to
metabolism parsed day one but then when
you have I sell Habana sites and the
Berkley device and 3d on the bottom
right you see again affirmation effects
of energy and that is very consistent on
the perhaps of the slightly lower levels
then in the University of Pittsburgh
device so our conclusions from this
particular experiment that 2d culture is
just everyone knows they're really not
suitable for metabolism studies but then
these 3d micro physiological devices
from both laboratories really maintain
metabolic function as much as they
maintain the basic functionality of
parasites and it's you know again what
we've seen before this source of cells
is very important and CDI cells are
something that is reproduced more from
the same donor and as we all know aside
from that a primary will be exhausted
eventually and having a different batch
or a different donor they would produce
experiment to experiment variability so
let me conclude with couple of slides
here so what have we learned doing
testing of micro physiological systems
over two years first thing that
surprised me that we were actually able
to do this
it sounds daunting to be able to
transfer technology that is very
complicated from different labs
but once you have dedicated staff and
once you understand what the workflows
are and once you have help from the
developers it is actually possible and
again I'd like to appreciate both staff
that we had here and also our
collaborators who have gone out of their
way to help us establish this technology
transfer it's also very important that
all of our data are in the University of
Pittsburgh by the physiological database
and over two years we have run about
1,300 different chips and about 5,000
you know 2d experiments we have
collected tens of thousands data points
and hundreds of images and all of this
information will be available one year
after we have concluded depositing the
data engineers to Pittsburgh part of the
logical systems database to invite all
of you to access that site and and start
visiting that regularly because the data
will be released our kidney data for
example is is now in public domain now
detailed descriptions of all the kinetic
endpoints and equipment as necessary and
very detailed protocols this is also
something that we'll be adding to the
University of Pittsburgh microphysical
systems database this is very important
for the potential use of this technology
by end users because it's not enough to
just have a publication and then
materials method section or even a
protocol from a developer lab from
people who actually do this every day so
the detailed protocols that we develop
would be potentially very very useful
there are very typical challenges in
every platform is different and we do
not stop to be surprised how different
these technologies are and you have to
have a very open mind working with any
of them but what we found is not all
developers are open to sharing their
technology and that's okay I mean not
everyone is willing to give their
devices to someone else to try and test
some of the devices and the quality you
know how to make them that there's a lot
of material science and there's a lot of
you know with ography and printing that
it goes into that and rigorous quality
controlling of devices or cells is very
very important likewise quality of cells
that are used in micro physiological
systems and devices is equally important
sometimes these cells are not available
especially if the about if the platforms
were developed with primary cell
and then there are you know different
devices have different levels of
technical complexity and you have to be
prepared to deal with that but there are
also a lot of opportunities we are
continuing this work for the next two
years we have six our existing partners
and five new partners who have agreed to
continue working with us and we have 19
micro physiological systems that we aim
to test in the next two years for 2018
to 2020 we do see that developers are
generally interested in the feedback
that we provide and then a number of
stakeholders both folks in the pharma
and the chemical industry are generally
interested in in our experiences and we
are doing a lot of visits to talk to
them about what we have found and how
this technology can better be ported but
I really am or feeling that I'm a
representative a potential customer so I
do have a number of thoughts as well to
share with you
I do believe that this technology is
extremely useful and very promising and
that my engineering research and
development needs further support
however the applications of this tissue
chips will be finally fit for purpose
and I do not believe that in the short
term the next three to five years these
digital and Replace animals or even in
vitro studies I hope that some of these
devices will be ready but in reality
we're in the short term were not
replacing animal testing and from all of
you listening I think you have to you
know really you know believe in this
technology to start replacing data that
you're used to from standard and neutral
studies or from animal studies but the
developers also need to appreciate the
they need for Portability and ease of
use and reasonable cost of these devices
these are not easy to work with these
are not less expensive than traditional
feature studies or even animal studies
and somewhere that balances between the
throughput and the cost of these
complicated technology you know I'm not
sure we have a very good comfortable
understanding of that yet and when
people think that really it's the bridge
between the developers and then the
regulatory agencies I think that first
bridge is between the developers and
then the users who develop data will
then go to regulatory agencies but the
end-users companies that a lot of your
listening really
to be ready to be thinking about these
technologies and they need to have the
workforce that is ready to start working
with this
you know toxicologists or biologists may
or may not be immediately comfortable
using this technology so thinking of who
you hire and how to train staff is also
very important
but then the regulatory agencies the
decision-makers both internally and
externally to companies also need to be
educated about what the state of art is
and what it can and cannot do right now
and the work of our Center and our
statures my college is very important in
this regard but finally what type of
validation really we need to think about
in terms of issue chips validation is
very standard and very well-defined
process for in vitro methods that
replace animal press petition ships are
far more complicated and if the
technology that's still being very
actively developed and the real
validation of the one that exists in
Europe where there is network of testing
laboratories of others a ring trial net
methodology this is really not that is
ready in my opinion right now for this
very complicated technology and again
technology that is still in the early
stages of development organic validation
you know misses kind of what our Center
has been doing and you know sometimes
felt like you know very complicated
thing because these devices are our
engineering devices and there are lots
of connections there are lots of tricks
that you need to learn and you really
need to be ready for this but finally
what I think really is going to take
hold and this is something where we're
working with next is the faithful
purpose validation the industry that our
users need to define how they you know
what questions they think are ready for
tissue chips and then that information
has to be embraced by developers to be
able to develop technology that fits
that particular question rather than
developing a technology that replaces a
particular animal or an organ system so
I really appreciate your time listening
to this I'll be happy to answer any
questions and with that I will conclude
thank you
Thank You dr. wissen for that
informative presentation I would also
like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible now
before we go I want to let everyone know
that this webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through May of 2019 as
a final reminder our speaker will follow
up with any questions you've submitted
via email that's all for now thank you
for joining us and we hope to see you
again soon goodbye